what did you do hmm do you have any  remorse what did you do what did you do  dog oh my god you made a hole in the  door I think you did it wasn't you you  tore this up yeah it was it was you what  is this you know if there's a bad brown  dog they did time behind here was this  you how about you mister did you destroy  a pillow this wasn't yours were you bad  what have you done buck by bad boy and  here's what Berlin did today and when  she was questioned about it she's not  holding out in the shower she's praying  that we blames a bit else did you get on  the counter and get those cookies Livie  what's wrong would you do ravish me give  you the garbage yeah come here  who peed over here well I guess that  answers that no here's the boy alright  don't care anything else up okay hold on  all that